[Music]
hey everyone its Alicia Malone welcome
to another episode of Fandango indie
movie Guide and the Oscars are only just
a couple of days away so let's get into
my final round of predictions for the
biggest category of all Best Picture
let's take a look at the nominees first
we have call me by your name the
heartbreaking movie by Luca Guadagnino
based on a book of the same name
starring Timothy sha'lame and Armie
Hammer as two guys who have a little bit
of a fling over summer in Italy in the
1980s darkest hour is directed by Joe
Wright it stars Gary Oldman and it's
about the war in Britain right at the
darkest moment when Winston Churchill
took over as Prime Minister
Dunkirk could almost be a companion
piece to darkest hour directed by
Christopher Nolan it's also about a dark
time in world war 2 the Battle of
Dunkirk told from 3 different
perspectives incredibly tense and
beautifully made get out is the horror
comedy-drama social commentary mash up
by Jordan Peele starring Daniel Kaluga
as a guy who goes to his white
girlfriend's house for the weekend and
ends up finding much much more than he
bargained for
Lady Bird the charming comedy drama
directed and written by Greta Gerwig
starring Saoirse Ronan as a young girl
he wants to leave Sacramento and move to
New York
phantoms thread is directed by Paul
Thomas Anderson PTA it's about a
designer in the 1950s London who likes
to use women as his muses men discard
them starring Daniel day-lewis the post
is a tense and very timely film directed
by Steven Spielberg all about the
publishing of the Pentagon Papers in the
1970s with an all-star cast including
Meryl Streep and Tom Hanks the shape of
water a gorgeous monster film by
guillermo del toro starring sally
hawkins as a mute janitor working in a
shady government lab during the Cold War
who falls in love with a fish man and
three billboards outside a being
Missouri directed by Martin
McDonagh who also wrote the screenplay
it's about a mother who is fed up with
the local police for not doing enough to
try to solve her daughter's murder
starring Frances McDormand
Sam Rockwell and Woody Harrelson for my
prediction this one is really difficult
this category is the closest to call and
it's actually the hardest to predict but
I'm gonna put it out there I'm gonna
save the shape of water it is difficult
for the shape of water because it didn't
get a SAG nomination and it is very very
hard for a movie to win best picture
without getting a SAG nomination but
it's not impossible so my money's on the
shape of water wouldn't discount three
billboards outside every Missouri or
maybe even get out in the same category
oh it's hard to predict this one I have
no idea which way it's going to go but
that is what makes it the most exciting
and if you're staying home this weekend
you can see call me by your name the
shape of water and also faces places on
Fandango now faces places of course is
the documentary directed by jr. and
Agnes Varda little road trip for them as
they go around northern France you know
Photo Booth fan taking pictures of
people and facing them up
larger-than-life Oscars the proposed
sixth and on magazine interviews demands
around two fukuko
so to me I'm creamy so tipsy just said
the porcelain you can see faces places
plus call me by your name and the shape
of water on Fandango now right now so in
a couple of days we will know if my
predictions are right or not but I want
to hear from you who do you think will
take out Best Picture let me know in the
comments below or you can tweet me
adulation Malone and I'll see you next
week with the results have beat Oscars
bite
[Music]